yo no sé si ustedes les pasa pero a mí
me ocurre todo el tiempo cuando veo la
relación de los países que presentan los
altos niveles de calidad de vida y
bienestar social siempre me pregunto qué
sucede en esos lugares que hace la
diferencia porque esos países pueden
ofrecerle a sus habitantes un mayor
nivel de bienestar a la hora que me
pongo a revisar sus indicadores pues en
efecto me encuentro con una larga lista
de buenas prácticas que justamente
promueven esos resultados pero hay una
característica en particular que destaca
en todos esos países y que les da una
ventaja competitiva con respecto al
resto de los países del mundo
y es que sus ciudadanos muestran un alto
nivel de corresponsabilidad con su
comunidad sobre todo en tres pilares
fundamentales que hacen que esos países
sean más fuertes
denme la oportunidad de compartir con
ustedes cuáles son esos tres pilares y
de ahí partir para poder defender la
idea de que ser un buen ciudadano es
mucho mejor
el primer pilar en el que los ciudadanos
trabajan fuertemente para que sus países
tengan un alto nivel de calidad de vida
y bienestar social es cumplir la ley
y poner en perspectiva que las leyes son
el instrumento para construir la paz
social
cuando no cumplimos la ley estamos
provocando una terrible desigualdad
entre ciudadanos le abrimos la puerta a
los abusos a los privilegios a la
inequidad
la cultura de la legalidad se rompe
cuando los ciudadanos carecemos de una
conciencia legal
déjenme les doy un dato que me va a
permitir defender esto que les estoy
compartiendo según el informe país 2018
que elabora el ine y que mide la calidad
de la ciudadanía en méxico 66 por ciento
de las y los mexicanos 66 de cada 100
escuchen el dato creemos que la ley se
cumple poco o nada lo cual es una
muestra evidente que los mexicanos se
nos hace muy fácil incumplir la ley nos
parece inofensivo
desde las infracciones más simples como
estacionarnos en doble fila pero eso sí
como somos muy conscientes y muy
respetuosos ponemos la intermitente como
si al poner la intermitente anular amos
la infracción que estamos cometiendo o
como que al poner la intermitente
echáramos abajo el caos vial y el riesgo
en el que nos estamos poniendo y
poniendo a la gente que transita a
nuestro alrededor
así que así estamos en este país con ese
nivel de conciencia y bueno esto me
permite también hablar de que al final
de cuentas en méxico hay que venir
construyendo una mayor conciencia de la
legalidad quisiera ser un ejercicio si
ustedes me ayudan ojalá y me den la
oportunidad de interactuar con ustedes y
que podamos levantar la mano quien
quiera ayudarme
si les llega así a bote pronto algún
recuerdo de cuando hayamos infringido
alguna norma desde las más simples o
cómo es estacionarnos en doble fila o
alguna más compleja como haber alterado
algún reporte de trabajo o haberle
puesto algún ajuste a la declaración
anual de impuestos quisiera ver manos
arriba si me ayudan al cabo que lo que
aquí digamos aquí se queda nadie nos ve
y nadie nos escucha mano arriba
que no les dé pena que no les dé pena lo
ven
es un tema cultural vivimos con la
convicción de que tanto es tantito
todo el mundo lo hace
no pasa nada pero saben qué
si para los ciudadanos responsables
combaten la impunidad garantizan el
cumplimiento de la ley si cumpliéramos
la ley todos tendríamos los mismos
derechos habría más oportunidades y por
supuesto también tendríamos las mismas
obligaciones por eso insisto en defender
que cumplir la ley es un deber que no
podemos eludir porque ser un buen
ciudadano es mucho mejor
cuál es el pilar número 2
que trabajan muy fuerte los ciudadanos
que viven en países con un alto nivel de
calidad de vida y bienestar social
y ser solidarios
la solidaridad es el soporte de una
sociedad próspera y moderna y además
guarda una estrecha relación con el
nivel de felicidad de quien la practica
les cuenta una historia se trata de un
antropólogo que estudiaba los usos y
costumbres de una tribu en áfrica
analizaba las conductas los
comportamientos de los integrantes de la
comunidad
un día decidió trabajar con niños así
que compró una buena cantidad de dulces
los colocó en una canasta que luego puso
al pie de un árbol
mandó llamar a los niños para invitarlos
a participar a la actividad y
explicarles la regla del juego
les dijo cuando yo grita corran
ustedes van a correr a toda velocidad
hasta que el árbol
el que corra más rápido y llegue primero
toma la canasta y se queda con todos los
dulces
los niños se pusieron
en la línea de juego
a esperar la instrucción el antropólogo
gritó corran los niños se tomaron de la
mano corrieron a toda velocidad hasta el
punto marcado llegaron juntos agarraron
la canasta y se repartieron los dulces
el antropólogo
no sabía bien a bien que había ocurrido
de pronto pensó que los niños no habían
entendido correctamente la instrucción
se les acerque les pregunta
porque corrieron todos juntos
se trataba de que el que corriera más
rápido y llegara primero tomará la
canasta y se quedara con todos los
dulces
los niños respondieron
y porque uno de nosotros iba a estar
feliz
y todos los demás iban a estar tristes
moraleja
solidarios fortalece la felicidad y esto
me da la pauta para compartirles un
segundo dato méxico ocupa la posición
106 en el índice de solidaridad por
países este lo elabora la charity hay
fundation en coordinación con la firma
de comunicación francesa gallup que mide
los niveles de solidaridad de 139 países
del mundo basándose en tres rasgos
fundamentales
aportaciones económicas ayuda a los
desconocidos y participación en
actividades de voluntariado
países como neymar y kenia lideran este
ranking lo cual es una clara muestra que
no se necesita ser una potencia
económica para ser solidarios sino más
bien de aspirar a convertirnos en
mejores seres humanos
qué paradójico no convertirnos en
mejores seres humanos por eso insisto
que ser un buen ciudadano es mucho mejor
y aquí voy a hacer un segundo ejercicio
si ustedes me ayudan ya que estamos más
en confianza y que ya nos conocemos
mejor vamos a ver qué tan solidarios
somos en esta sala no voy a preguntar
sobre aportaciones económicas porque
alguien podría decirme héctor pues
apenas libramos la quincena no no voy a
preguntar tampoco en ayuda a los
desconocidos porque alguien me puede
decir con estos niveles de inseguridad
como nos pide es ayudar a los
desconocidos voy a preguntar y pediré
una vez más el favor de levantar las
manos quienes de nosotros participamos o
hemos participado en actividades de
voluntariado y por favor actividades más
o menos formales no cuando éramos scouts
hoy vamos a las misiones y llevamos una
despensa un domingo a la sierra de
álvarez eso no
vale actividades formales de
voluntariado marcha arriba
bueno no me fue tan mal yo pensé que que
iba a decir que contribuyamos a la
posición 106 del ranking mundial
ustedes no contribuyen ustedes más bien
si le ponen mucho empeño si por ustedes
fuera méxico tendría una mejor posición
en ese ranking y bueno pues tercer o
tercer pilar le dije que eran tres
tercer pilar en el que trabajan muy
fuerte los ciudadanos para consolidar
países con un alto nivel en su calidad
de vida y bienestar promover la cultura
de la paz que estamos haciendo nosotros
desde nuestros espacios para frenar el
espiral de violencia que parece no tener
fin
el investigador neozelandés deivid bogan
realizó un estudio para identificar las
400 palabras más usadas en el mundo
la palabra número en todos los idiomas
la palabra número 24 si consideramos que
el universo es de 400 la 24 es de las
más usadas es la palabra problema
siempre estamos dispuestos a encontrarle
un problema a todo
pero eso no es lo más triste saben cuál
es la palabra que ni siquiera aparece en
la lista de las 400 más usadas en todos
los idiomas cuál creen
cual
alguien expolio mi plática porque ya lo
sabía
alguien espoleó mi plática efectivamente
la palabra que no aparece en la lista de
las 400 más usadas en el mundo es la
palabra solución y aquí les doy un
tercer y último dato ya que estamos
hablando de rankings internacionales no
les quiero matar la onda pero según el
informe de pascullo al 2018 que elabora
el instituto australiano de economía y
paz y que mide los niveles de paz el 163
países méxico ocupa la nada honrosa
posición 140
y alguien me puede decir pues si es que
como habrá paz en un país con tanta
pobreza y con tanta desigualdad yo les
quiero contar del caso de cambia cambia
es un país ubicado en áfrica
sub-sahariana una de las zonas más
pobres y más desiguales del mundo pues
cambia en este informe de paz global
2018 escaló 35 posiciones hoy ocupa el
lugar número 76 méxico el 140 por eso
insisto en que no necesariamente es un
resultado de la pobreza y de la
desigualdad en gambia han entendido que
formar mejores ciudadanos también
contribuye a promover la paz por eso
insisto esta noche con ustedes en que
ser un buen ciudadano
mucho mejor
y estoy seguro que cada uno de ustedes
podría aportar una buena razón para ser
un buen ciudadano basta con convertir
pequeñas acciones positivas en hábitos
cotidianos con construir todas y todos
una comunidad donde podamos vivir mejor
respetarnos ayudarnos y porque no hasta
querernos un poco
intentémoslo podríamos llevarnos una
grata sorpresa y como dice john lewis
puede que nosotros no hayamos escogido
el momento pero el momento nos ha
escogido a nosotros así que yo los
invito a que juntos hagamos un gran
tándem y nos convirtamos en mejores
ciudadanos muchísimas gracias